Hey and how's it going my name is Paula
Deepa
today we revisit some old friends that I
haven't met in a long time
facade is a game where you meet this
couple and we have to figure out how to
save or ruin their relationship
I am busy picking my character I will be
my favorite gonzalo oh god oh god it's
so great to see you little girl how's it
going
I missed you buddy what don't give me
that look
Wow you should visit more often oh I
missed that great asset grace I can
[ __ ] hear you
oh there's grace Gonzalo yes I can see
you look fabulous so please make
yourself at home I can see you still
look like a [ __ ] okay and vile oh why
this evening is over already
babe we just started come on it's fine
you should just go Oh hallo Gonzalo is
me thank you
and schools got schools under me I know
now here we are yes good very good
daddy yes yes I love your paints they
are shot well
Gonzalo that's kind of a bold way to say
hello I am not sweating any paint
[Music]
well I'm just gonna pour you a glass of
his wine okay no no oh great one thing
yeah maybe you'd like some juice or
mineral water I want some pasta
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh well nice thing to say and I'm sure
grace appreciates that yep
I haven't water well please go look at
trips Italy photo great
why are you where we wasn't where is
what did you
he is this even after a full day's work
designing magazine ad race somehow finds
time to decorate and I can do this but
sometimes I want to start fresh
there's my nipple touch yours grace
that's it
you've got to leave what if I don't
knock in the door what happens then ah
[Music]
valium how did you know I did you know I
hear and like your melons well you like
your melons by school that's it come
you've got them come on mate I'll just
sit here in the corner
[Music]
ha he can't even see me I thought I
heard someone out here ah been so long
since we've seen you you're not even
hitting me melon ha ha ha well you know
what I'm just gonna make you a martini
no no Gonzalo maybe you'd like just a
simple glass of white wine
I want to drink your
or maybe some melon juice what did I say
something weird since Allah is Gonzalo
from what you said before about the
[ __ ] balls all right Alice fun Oh
sounds fun to revisit some all the good
old classics you bros enjoy this video
go ahead and leave a like it I think it
was fun and I'll the zebras in the next
one thanks for watching and as always
stay awesome it's my favorite talk to
tall one you come to talk to the girl
[Music]